شعاره الاثير انه باق ويتمدد اما هم فقد
يصلح شعارا لهم ان الحرب تطول وتطول
الحديث هنا عن تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه من
جهه والقوات الامريكيه والدوليه والقوات
العراقيه والميليشيات المتحالفه معها من
جهه اخرى تتوالى تصريحات القاده العسكريين
الامريكيين بشان الحرب الطاحنه مع تنظيم
الدوله منذ اكثر من عامين والجديد فيها
اعلان القائد العام لقوات التحالف الدولي
والقوات الامريكيه في العراق في الوقت
نفسه الجنرال ستيفن تاونسند ان القضاء على
هذا التنظيم في كل من العراق وسوريا
سيتطلب عامين اضافيين على الاقل من القتال
الشرس ناصر اي طاهر لديه
المزيد ليس بعد اسابيع او شهور فعداديه
الامريكي بدا العمل سيلزم التحالف الدولي
بقياده واشنطن عامان اضافيان من القتال
العنيف لازاله معقلي تنظيم الدوله في
الرقه والموصل ثم سحق ما سيتبقى من
مقاتليه في الصحراء الواقعه بين سوريا
والعراق يقولها قائد امريكي بارز على
اعتاب الموصل التي بشر مسؤولوه في
البنتاجون قبلا باستردادها قبل تنصيب
الرئيس المنتخب دونالد ترامب هي ذاتها
الموصل العصيه التي طالما وعدت الحكومه
العراقيه بحسم المعركه فيها قبل حلول
نهايه العام واذا كانت بغداد تصر على
الحديث عن تقدم في ثبات فان لدى
الامريكيين حتما من المعطيات ما يجعلهم
اقل
تفاؤلا
المقاومه الشرسه التي يبديها مقاتل تنظيم
الدوله وهجماتهم المضاده ابطات سير
العمليات التي دخلت واشنطن على خطها بقوه
انها تنخرط مع القوات العراقيه بصوره اكبر
بعدما اعيد اطلاق حمله يقول قائد قوات
التحالف انها توقفت لاراحه المقاتلين لا
احد يعرف كم وقفه للراحه واعاده التاهب
القتالي ستعرف المراحل المقبله من عمر
الحرب على تنظيم الدوله ولا يعرف ايضا ما
اذا كان التقديرات الامريكيه الجديده تنم
عن قله الثقه في القدرات القتاليه
لشركائها العراقيين من قوات وميليشيات
يقول الجنرال ستيفن تاوسند انه سبق وابلغ
بغداد بحاجه القوات العراقيه للراحه بين
الحين والاخر فحتى القصف الجوي يصوره
الامريكيون كاجراء لرفع معنويات تلك
القوات لكن بعد كل الدعم والمسانده التي
يقدمها التحالف لبغداد في معركه الموصل
بدا وكانما قرر اخيرا تولي زمام الامور
يبدو ان معرفه واشنطن بقدرات تنظيم الدوله
ليست اقل من معرفتها بالميليشيات التي
تقاتل الى جانب القوات العراقيه الجنرال
تاونسند راى في قانون الحشد الشعبي ما قد
يجعل العراق اكثر امنا لكن بشرط ان يصبح
عناصره جزءا من حرس وطني لا ان يبقوا دما
ايرانيه على حد وصفه يقول تاونسند ان
الخيار البشع هو ان يصبح الحشد الشعبي
ذراعا عراقيه لا
فهل
سح هل انهم جا له مختلفه ايا كانت المهمه
فانها تشهد تغييرا في التخطيط يبقي
الخيارات
مفتوحه ومن يعرف لعل هؤلاء الجنود
الامريكيين سيحتفلون باعياد ميلاد لا حصر
لها على هذه
الارض انضم الينا من واشنطن دان سروار
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جونز
هوبكنز والباحث في معهد الشرق الاوسط ومن
اسطنبول العميد الركن حاتم كريم الفلاحي
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي العراقي
سياده
العميد بالنسبه
للكلام عن القضاء على تنظيم الدوله في
بدايه هذه المعركه على الموصل كان الحديث
يتحدث عن او يدور حول شهور معدوده لكن
الان تحول الى عامين من القتال العنيف هل
تعتقد ان قوات التحد
الدولي او الولايات المتحده تحديدا في قلب
هذا التحالف تريد فعلا القضاء على تنظيم
الدوله ام انها انه يمثل بالنسبه لها
الدجاجه التي تضع بيضا من الذهب وتسمح
للولايات المتحده بالتدخل في اي شان كان
في العراق او غيره من
المنطقه نعم تحيه لك ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره
ولضيفك
الكريم انا اعتقد بانه ما يجري الان من
انتشار القوات الامريكيه هو عمليه اعاده
انشار في المنطقه سبق وان تكلمنا في هذا
الموضوع بان القوات الامريكيه المتواجده
حاليا في العراق بهذه الاعداد الضخمه التي
تصل الى اكثر من 5000 عسكري موجود في
العراق ما بين الفرقه 101 وما بين قوات
خاصه وما بين مستشارين وما الى ذلك اعتقد
بان هذا الحجم الكبير لا يمكن ان نقول
بانهم مستشارين يمكن ان يقدموا المشوره
العسكريه للقطاعات او القوات الحكوميه
بحيث ان هذه اعداد المستشارين يمكن ان
تكون اعداد قليله وتتواجد الى مستوى
اللواء او الى مستوى الافواج اما ان تكون
الاعداد بهذه النسبه وبهذه بهذه الكثافه
وبهذه الاعداد فاعتقد بان لهذا الامر ما
بعده وانا اعتقد بانه عمليه انتشار للقوات
الامريكيه في العراق وفي المنطقه لان كانت
هناك تغيرات كبيره جدا على المسرح
الاقليمي اجبرت القوات الامريكيه على ان
تغير من استراتيجيتها بعد ان كانت الاعداد
والتخطيط وتقديم الاستشاره والاسناد الى
توا الحقائق التي س بناء على هذه الحقائق
التي سقتها اسال السيد دانيل من
واشنطن كل هذه القوات التي تحشد الولايات
المتحده في العراق هل هي غير قادره قوات
قوه عظمى غير قادره على سحق تنظيم ميليشيا
مسلحه موجوده في اماكن محدده في العراق
وسوريا
اعتقد انه من الخطا في
الشك في التزام الولايات المتحده بهزيمه
تنظيم
الدوله
القوه الاكبر التي
تحارب تنظيم الدوله هي القوات العراقيه
بما في ذلك الحشد الشعبي
وغيرها وليس 5000 امريكيين من الامريكيين
الذين يلعبون دورا
داعما حرب الموصل لن لن تصل الى سنتين
ستاخذ اقل بكثير من ذلك اما رقه فهي
مختلفه لانه ليس هناك حكومه تدعم
رقه هناك
قوات
من الشركس
والاكراد الذين يتنافسون
لاحتلال رقه والوضع مختلف تماما
والامريكيون سوف يكونون حارسين على تبطئ
لانهم لا يعرفون من الذي
سوف يسيطر على المدينه بعد هزيمه تنظيم
الدوله سياده العميد الفلاحي هناك تساؤلات
عن استراتيجيه القوات العراقيه
والميليشيات المتحالفه معها فيما يتعلق
بقتال تنظيم الدوله ومدى نجاعه هذه
الاستراتيجيه مساله الجند بين الفتره
والاخرى لماذا لا تعتمد الضغط المباشر
والمستمر على تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
وتحريك القطاعات باراحه الجند الذين في
المواجهه وتحريك بدلا منهم قطاعات اخرى لم
تكن في المواجهه لماذا الاصرار على طرد
تنظيم الدوله من المدن الرئيسيه واهمال
القرى والبلدات الصغيره التي له فيها حضور
واضح
وانتشار بين وواضح
ايضا
نعم بدايه خطه الموصل انتابتها كثير من
الخلل هذه الخطه انا اعتقد بان كان يجب ان
تكون معركه الموصل كمدينه منفصله عن عن عن
القرى والمدن المحيطه بمدينه الموصل وهذا
ما جعل القوات الحكوميه تصل الى مدينه
الموصل وهي منهكه ومتعبه من معارك سابقه
اضف الى هذا بان هذه القوات دخلت على طوال
هذا العام بمعارك متعدده سواء من الفلوجه
او الرما دي الى الرطبه الى هيت الى كبيسه
الى الشرقاط الى القياره وهذه هذه المناطق
جميعها كانت فيها مقاومه وكان فيها انهاك
كبير جدا للقوات الحكوميه اضف الى هذا
بانه في في في في المعارك يجري تحليل
منطقه الحركات عندما يجري تحليل منطقه
الحركات يدرس الطقس بصوره مفصله درجات
الحراره الامطار وما الى ذلك وانا اعتقد
بان القوات هنا اخطات خطا كبير جدا في
تحليل تحليل من طقه الحركات وبهذا الان
يتحججون
بانه بان الطقس اجبر القوات على ايقاف
الهجوم و واخذ استراحه لهذه القطاعات على
ان تكون بقفزات تعبو ولكن الحقيقه هو انه
ما جرى بان المحور الشمالي توقف تماما
بعدم قدره الفرقه 16 على التقدم المحور
الجنوبي الشرقي الجنوبي اجبر هذا المحور
قطعات الفرقه المدرعه التاسعه على التوقف
في حي الوحده عندما اعطت خسائر كبيره جدا
بفوج المغاوير ولواء 36 اجبر هذه القوات
على التقهقر وسحب قسم من قوات مكافحه
الارهاب من المحور الشرقي لتفادي الموقف
في هذا في هذا المحور وبالتالي نحن نتكلم
عن اخفاقات كبيره جدا انتابت هذه الخطه
نتيجه عدم وصول المحاور جميعها بصوره على
على الجهه الاخرى دعني اسال السيد دانيل
من واشنطن على قدره واشنطن على ضبط ايقاع
شركائها وحلفائها في قتال تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه كان هذا السؤال يمثل الرهان
الاساسي الذي يمكن ان يحدد مدى نجاعه او
افلاح القوات الامريكيه وحلفائ في طرد
تنظيم الدوله من المدن او سحق هذا التنظيم
البش مرجا لهم اجنده مختلفه عن اجنده
الحشد الشعبي عن اجنده الحكومه العراقيه
التي تبدو في حاله من الضعف الشديد او
الدوله العراقيه في حاله من الضعف الشديد
اذاء او في مواجهه مكونات داخل هذه الدوله
كالحشيش مختلفه الولايات المتحده بطبيعه
طبيعه الحال لها اهداف
مختلفه انا لست متاكدا من انها تضبط
النسق لكن
هناك وحده بين هذه القوى
المتباينه وذلك يتطلب ان تكون مرنا مع بعض
القوات لانها تكون متعبه وتحتاج الى
الراحه اعتقد انهم يحاربون بشكل جيد معا
ويتقدمون حول الموصل باستثناء ما حصر في
الاسابيع الاخيره
السابقه
وربما المعركه ستحسم في خلال شهور وليست
تلك مشكله كبيره المشكله الكبيره هو كيف
يتم تتم اداره المدينه وما هي الاضرار
التي ستلحق بالمدينه خلال المعارك وهذه
مشاكل كبيره جدا الرقه الوضع فيها اكثر
سوءا لانه لا توجد حكومه
شرعيه ستعاد تعود اليها اداره الرقه بعد
الفوز شكرا جزيلا لك السيد دانييل سروار
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جونز
هوبكنز والبحث في معهد الشرق الاوسط وكان
معنا من اسطنبول العميد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
العراقي شكرا شكرا جزيلا لكما بهذا نصل
الى نهايه الحصاد السلام عليكم ورحمه
[موسيقى]
الله